this is one of those stories that is only
shocking if you're not paying attention.
Donald Trump reportedly said Jews.
Here we go now.
Jews are only in it for themselves after a
recent call with Jewish leaders, according
to a new report.
Is anybody really shocked by this?
And I know people will often come back and
say.
But Trump's son in law is Jewish.
Trump can't be anti-Semitic.
But Trump's daughter converted to Judaism.
But Trump's grand.
Kids are Jewish.
But Trump move the embassy from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem, I even got a call about this actually
on on voicemail earlier this week, which I
played for you.
This is why all of that stuff is is meaningless
by every reasonable estimation.
Donald Trump has the same tired old stereotypical
views about Jewish folks, about black folks,
about Hispanic folks.
It's all the same stuff.
So, you know, yes, Jews are only in it for
themselves.
This is what Trump reportedly said in front
of officials, according to a new report from
The Washington Post.
More than two dozen current and former administration
officials told The Washington Post about Trump's
private views on race and described racist
remarks that he has made while in office.
It's a widely sourced story.
More than 20 people talking about what they
observed.
The Washington Post writes that the president's
characterization of Jews happened after he
got off the phone with Jewish lawmakers during
a conference call last week with American
Jews.
Trump reportedly said, We love your country,
referring to Israel as if Israel is the country
of American Jews, which is another trope.
He also told an audience of Jewish Americans
that Israeli leader Benjamin Netanyahu is
your prime minister, which is wild.
Trump has previously called Jews who are Democrats
disloyal.
And these are all common anti-Semitic tropes
that have been around for a long time.
The idea that American Jews hold some greater
allegiance to Israel or a dual loyalty.
Many of these are folks who have never even
been to Israel, that they are more loyal to
Israel than their actual countries of birth
or of residence.
And at this point, the surprising thing is
not that Trump is accused of saying this stuff.
The surprising thing is that anybody's shocked
by it.
Now, let's let's dig in a little more into
one aspect of this.
This idea, this trope of Jews are in it for
themselves.
Most people are, generally speaking, concerned
with their own well-being.
Look at Republicans right now with the Supreme
Court.
Are they in this for anybody but themselves
and their own, the preservation of their ideology?
This is the absurdity of some of these tropes
that are stuck to one group.
Oh, you know, the trope of the Jews love money.
They're in it for the money.
Do do do white people hate money?
Do white people not care about money?
Black people don't care about money.
Sikhs, they're against money.
Women hate money.
Middle aged people hate money.
That's part of the absurdity of some of these
tropes that some of them are so vague and
meaningless that it actually boggles the mind
how people can seriously consider them assessments
of a particular group.
It's absurd.
And Trump, of course, is able to so casually
go from one race sister xenophobic trope to
the next almost second nature to him.
It it really seems to come very naturally
to him.
Now, do I tell you this because I think it's
going to, you know, alter the election results?
No, the people that are supporting Trump at
this point are not going to be dissuaded because
Trump said Jews are only in it for themselves.
The people who are already voting for Trump
at this late stage in the game are not going
to be dissuaded because of Trump's racially
tinged message that Joe Biden will destroy
the suburbs by looking at how housing policy
can have racial repercussions.
These people are with Trump no matter what.
The reason I tell you about this is to just
remind you that very often we just have to
believe what's plain as day.
If it looks like a duck, if it sounds like
a duck, if it walks like a duck.
Mostly it's a duck.
That's really the concept of Ockham's Razor.
From the scientific world.
And that is exactly what we are seeing here
with Donald Trump.
No surprise whatsoever.
He is exactly what he appears to be.
A we have a fantastic program for you today.
We are going to talk about what is the risk
to Roe v. Wade if indeed Donald Trump replaces
Ruth Bader Ginsburg with a Handmaid's Tale
like idealogue from the American right.
We are also going to talk about.
I mentioned undecided voters and decided voters
who are the undecided voters right now, we
have actually have some data about them and
we're going to talk about that a little bit
later.
We're going to take some of your phone calls.
And we have so much going on next week.
Not only do we have a week of shows and a
week of bonus shows, if you are a member,
which you should be at, join Pacman dot com.
We have the first presidential debate, Biden
vs. Trump Tuesday night.
Join me on your choice.
YouTube, Twitch or Facebook, whichever you
like best.
Join me at eight thirty p.m. Eastern, five
thirty p.m. Pacific for the first Biden vs.
Trump debate.
It's going to be wild The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman dot com.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.